I'm here with Andrea botes and we are
going to play a game on a wobbly chess
it's going to get very intense this is a
board that is supposed to be an art
piece but today we're going to use it
for competition and if you're King
wobbles all the way down that means you
resign well the pieces don't easily like
fall over it's actually a really nice
design they haven't met you look at that
I take him down okay
sorry we can also play like spinny moves
okay we throw little tricks yeah trick
shots and I'm going to have double
Eric's time so I'm going to use the
wobble to my advantage so 90 minutes to
three minutes no increments Good Luck
Good Luck May the wobble be with
you
okay oh suit I should not be SL respect
the wood I respect wood so sorry respect
the wobbles okay you've learned your
lesson from the past I'm very
embarrassed about how I recently played
that you like my spinny Bishop I don't
like it so I'm going to kick it out that
up how' you feel about that he's
wobbling
away we'll see you soon hi Anish how's
it going we are like w
games Channel go up to whoever wins
probably gets to post it to their
Channel yeah winner of the wobbly game
okay I going I got
nervous
someon yeah how do you feel been
preparing it is Hans course that you
using hans's course no no it's Alex
Pena's course okay yeah his private one
so many people have courses on the
jobava London I have nitz's course did
Hans actually make a jobava course I
couldn't tell if your please blow for
below the bells this I don't think he
made a Jaa he definitely did make a Jaa
oh really he did oh I'm sorry now it was
not
intentional okay the pressure is high
now I feel like there's pressure on me
too yeah you
too so the GMS approve of the joob
Baba don't know what are you doing I
feel like I could attack
you going to take my Pawn what if I
defend am I just up a pawn no I lose my
knight it's kind of hard to forget what
pieces you have when they're all
little cylinders be hard to forget and
easy to
remember or vice
versa I think I have to give it to
you you know what you can take my wobbly
Bishop oh God my King has almost he's
def find gravity right now it's
impressive okay you must overcome okay
am I allowed to put him back you can
adjust yeah
Jadu oh my gosh all right let's go with
the Rook okay we're already only up um
like 10 seconds now so our time odds I
appreciate I appreciate the leving
leveling of the
time oh my God that's a bishop this is a
it's genuinely so hard to see on this is
a bishop that's a queen okay that's all
right get your Pawn back oh yes my queen
trade a
sacrifice
I oh you wobbly chess where W it's very
tilting a very tilting game a little bit
disorienting I like that wobbly chest
has its fan
yeah we're going to mate you somehow
good luck Bishop good luck where are you
going
here you've got a dark squ
Bish he's coming in I don't want to
trade Jesus time is ticking pieces are
wobbling it's going to hit me with the
check patience no we need this guy oh my
God are you going to take my piece you
are you are you are you
are maybe maybe not okay
fine
got to be
quick oh my God my Rook is
hanging everything is falling down it's
hard to see the wly things why are you
so good at this you're so
fast okay it's a mix of talent and skill
I guess time is going to
take oh God I'm in check oh my God oh
God okay again rematch I'm going to play
wobbly chess until I beat you I'll take
the black pieces I think I need to play
with less time for the next
game okay we have one verse three wobbly
chess this is actually where Eric excels
um as we've seen he excels at not only
every variant but even the ones where
the pieces defy gravity oops so
hopefully this time odds will be enough
okay okay ready good luck good
luck it's getting very competitive
have to be very fast in this wobbly
chess I not a fan of this line I have to
be
faster it's okay take your time so do
you think you're better at wobbly chest
than normal chest because you're this is
you know your variant I mean I feel
pretty powerful thus far at this wobbly
game it's
Castle
oo Jesus Christ This is actually still
opening prep for me this is a line I
studied this years ago I don't have I
only have one move here so we're not
going to overthink we're we're following
uh the book on on the night C3 Sicilian
by GNE Jones when was the last time you
read this book probably about 10 years
ago okay all right that gives but he
shows this queen E5 move yeah it was a
nice move thank you okay so our Castle
has been ruined but that's okay you
don't need a castle all right you want
to push
there your KN on the side is looking
real nice what if I just okay got a
knight things are going to get dangerous
you know what let's get the king off the
file Knight and Bishop are working
together oh thanks for pointing that out
your king is physically shaking right
now God yeah I'm going to take my time
here you have a lot of this Pawn are you
will I be punished I have a check oh no
my Pawn typically what he says that it's
a trick but I genuinely I think it's
okay I'm going to take a
risk okay you know if we trade Queens
everything is going to be fine
mhm can we put these guys we don't have
a lot of
squares 36 seconds no I'm not going to
beat you on the wobbly board but I will
beat you on the clock no Queen trade for
you are you going with that he's
attacking my Pawn some oh my God and
we're pin okay can't do anything about
that I have we don't even have a
defense this is a very scary
position there goes it's about to get
scarier oh God I keep walking into these
traps well it's a a small Fork to give
you a check some pins invol my check
does nothing once you defend wow I
walked right into the flo also this is a
black R this is a white Rook we should
flip this I could even notice easy to to
get them confused I think we have no
choice here but to bz Gambit bz Gambit
and go for the dirty
flag could attack your queen and then
you're just going to
take okay 32
seconds
this position is very much
not okay this is a hideous hideous move
oh my God I don't even know where my my
four pieces adjust adjust adjust adjust
okay all right Don a queen nothing new
here
so passive he's taken everything and now
you're threatening me no mercy no mercy
all
right there's no defense here that's
time up Jesus Christ the game oh my God
okay okay one last try okay we've
already played a few games no we haven't
this is the first one this might in your
mind this is the first game got to start
fresh but now now we're we're 30 seconds
we're upping the odds this is good 30
seconds to 3 minutes on the wobbly board
here we go I think this is finally the
game I win Good Luck Good Luck er no
mercy no mercy G to give the pieces a
little spin oh why aren't they spinning
why do you this is very annoying because
this is a one line I haven't quite
studied it's like a reverse Queen's
Gambit okay my gosh I only have less
than 30 seconds yeah you don't have time
to adjust your wobbly
pieces to Bish line so what if maybe
well then I trapped my own Bishop so I
have to walk into
this this is fine we just Place some
friendly chess maybe a little bit of a
speed
chess where are you going to go with
that guy um if we trade we lose the pawn
so we don't like that let we
just you
take take you take okay 21 seconds oh
this is increment right no increments oh
no increment oh my God really felt bad
for everything on the line here okay
good if I win can I have the wobbly
board
uh May probably not but I'll give you
some merch the the merch okay we'll take
the
Merch this bishop needs to work with his
pieces o okay it doesn't work I know I
see what you're trying to do M Rosen I
take you take you take you take that
doesn't work just
yet really trying to mate me already I
can hear what you're trying to
do I'm a little worried about the
king it's getting a little scary
no okay we're playing clock mov so it's
not touch move no clock move is is not
touch move yeah okay uh I'll take it
anyways oo I see that you're taking my
Pawn spicy spicy we could take I don't
know I oh God okay when he says that I
don't calculate I just don't take it's
not worth the risk 10 seconds all right
the time ODS are working your queen is
almost falling down what are you trying
to do
there
um we're not getting
maen where okay okay okay this is a rook
this is a rook this is mine forget I
have no Bishop
uh adjust it was just tilting
me 53 seconds okay where you trying to
go
[Music]
here it's getting very
aggressive came out of
nowhere 34 seconds
what are
you oh my God this is not I'm not
getting mated I've got a
queen I got really lucky with that one
two seconds
yes is this where your king is yep
check and check okay oh my God okay it
was those are some intense time ons
almost unfair that was close though okay
good game I mean I was so close to
having the Ming attack really yeah I
really when you took I was scared but I
got really looking for the queen no you
defend fin won a
game I also think that the time mods
with the wobble were quite stacked but
it was intense though like no it was a
good wobbly game that was that was a
close fight